[Music]
three six months I know where I'll be at
the after-party three six I'll see you
three
two of them are English two of them are
American one of them is South African
American strange for them of fine ladies
one of them is a great Dame here are the
nominees for Actress in a leading role
[Music]
judi dench in mrs. Henderson presents
Charlize Theron in North Country
cure nightly in Pride and Prejudice
Felicity Huffman in Transamerica
reese witherspoon and walk the line
and the Oscar goes to Reese Witherspoon
walk the line
this is the first Academy Award
nomination for reese witherspoon beam
from nashville tennessee she need the
music the feeling the attitude and the
culture of the country music scene she
even played mamamoo go further and
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
never thought I'd be here maja life
grown up in Tennessee and I want to say
that Johnny Cash and June Carter had a
wonderful tradition of honoring other
artists and musicians and singers and I
really feel that tradition tonight it is
very important and and I really feel it
so I want to thank the Academy but this
incredible honor um I want to say thank
you to so many people who helped me
create this role um everyone at Fox
Kathy Conrad James Keach for producing
the film a very special thank you to Jim
Mangold who directed the film and also
wrote this character who is a real woman
who has dignity and honor and fear and
courage and she's a real woman and I
really appreciate that was incredible
gift that you gave me so thank you and
t-bone Burnett for helping me realize my
lifelong dream van a country music
singer Thank You t-bone and I want to
say thank you to Joaquin Phoenix who
[Applause]
this commitment and passion for this
character for this performance was just
remarkable and I feel so lucky to have
gone on this journey with you I'm so
blessed to have my family here tonight
my mother and my father here and um I
just want to say thank you so much for
everything for being so proud of me it
didn't matter if I was making my bed or
making a movie they never hesitated to
say how proud they were of me and that
means so very much to a child so thank
you mom and dad I want to say thank you
to my wonderful husband and my two
children who should be going to bed and
thank you for loving me so much and
supporting me and I want to say that my
my grandmother was one of the biggest
inspirations in my life she taught me
how to be a real woman to have strength
and self-respect and to never give those
things away and those are a lot of
qualities I saw in June Carter and
people used to ask June how how she was
doing and she used to say I'm
trying to matter and I know what she
means you know I'm just trying to matter
and live a good life and make work that
means something to somebody and you have
all made me feel that I might have
accomplished that tonight so thank you
so much for this honor
[Applause]
[Music]